[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants notre petit nuage
vous amène ce soir un jardinier jeu le
beau temps patron qui me donne envie de
faire du jardinage et bien bon courage
nounours et mes deux petites amies vont
muter ce qu'on va s'amuser dont
l'échelle est beau
bonsoir la petite maisonnée ce soir les
enfants
nous allons faire du jardinage et je
suis le jardinier qui fait jardinier un
jardinier
c'est un monsieur qui plante des fruits
des fleurs et des légumes
oui de petits pois méchant oui aussi
et vous savez vous planter le chou
savez-vous planter du jour à la mode à
la mode
savez vous planter les choux à la bonne
note de g je vais vous expliquer et vous
chanter avec moi on les plante avec le
doit à la mode à la mode
savez-vous planter les choux à la mode
de pas la mode ça ne vous paraît ainsi à
la mode de chez nous à vous de chanter
les enfants avec le plus à la mode la
mode de celui de total sont à la mode de
l'humour avec la main savez-vous planter
sont à la mode à la mode ça nous vous
planter l'essai à la mode de chez nous
avec le savent et en sont à la mode à la
mode ça me fait encore à la mode de chez
nous avec nous
toi
on les plante avec la côte à la mode de
la halle à moteur ou les gratins dégâts
dus à la bactérie
et vive le jardinage mais ce que ça
donne chaud je vais chercher un verre
d'eau nounours c'est très gentil mais il
est grand temps d'aller rouges tiennent
of bercy nicolas ce que ça fait du bien
mais où sont-ils ton passé
mes enfants exemple
non non tu sais pas quoi dont nicolas
les plaines de jeu des blacks aux jeunes
sont je suis en retard bonne nuit les
petits petit grand jardinier connu les
enfants fait comme nicolas et
pimprenelle
allez vite vous coucher est faite de
porc allons vite nous coucher loue aussi
patron les travaux manuels sa fatigue
est en route
jardiniers bonhommes bleus
oh
[Musique]
e
oh
m
vaud
[Musique]